[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVANG SHAH: I have
the great pleasure
of introducing a
friend as well as
one of the most
prominent figures
in the community, Soojin Kwon.
Soojin is the managing
director of the MBA admissions
and the overall program
at Michigan's Ross
School of Business.
She's also an adjunct lecturer
in business communications
at Ross.
Previous in her
life, she was also
a manager at
Deloitte consulting,
an analyst with the US
Senate Budget Committee,
and a Presidential Management
Fellow with the White House
Appropriations Committee
and Department of Commerce.
She holds an MBA
from Ross, a Master's
in Public Policy from Harvard's
Kennedy School of Government,
and a BA in Economics and
Political Science from Yale.
She's clearly not
very accomplished.
We're thrilled to
have Soojin here
to share perspective on her
career, her path, and then
a little bit about what's
happening in the MBA world
for all of you.
So Soojin, welcome, and
thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
SOOJIN KWON: Thank
you for having me.
When Devan and Angel asked me
to do this, I was thrilled.
And the context they
gave me was there
are a lot of Googlers
out there who
are interested in thinking about
the next step in their career,
and we thought it
might be useful
for you to share your own path.
And so I'm going
to start from way
back, from when I was a
child and when all of us
start to think
about, what do you
want to do when you grow up?
How many of you have
thought about that question
since childhood?
So what I was really young
before I went to grade school,
I thought, I want
to be a cashier
because I thought you got
to take home all the money
that you collected at
the end of the day.
And then I got a
little bit older.
I got a little bit wiser.
And I saw my parents
working really hard.
My parents are
immigrants from Korea.
And my dad was an
engineer, and my mom
worked at nights fixing
phones so she could be home
while we were home from school.
And they were constantly
working and taking care of us
around the clock.
And I thought,
wow, that is hard.
All I want to do when
I grow up is retire.
My parents said, no,
you've got to first work.
So then, as I went through
grade school and middle school,
I was one of a
handful of Asian kids
in a very white community right
outside of Ann Arbor actually.
And I grew up with a lot
of physical and personal
challenges to who I was
because of how I looked.
And right or wrong,
I happened to watch
the movie "The Godfather"
with my dad when I was young.
And I thought, when
I grow up, I want
to be the Godfather because
you can say take a hit out
on that person.
They've crossed me.
And my parents said
Soojin, no, that's
not the way to get ahead.
So then, when I got to
high school, what I saw
was still my parents
working really hard
and trying to make ends meet.
And our ends met,
but we had things
that we needed, not always
the things that I wanted.
And I thought, what I want--
back to my childhood-- is money.
I need to go work in business.
So I also grew up playing the
piano quite well a long time
ago.
And I had a decision to make
when I got into college.
I had gotten into
Michigan for music
and gotten a scholarship
to study music,
but I also got into Yale--
not for music, but for a
liberal arts education.
And I chose the
win-win solution,
which was to go to Yale
because my parents are Asian.
They have a desire to
have bragging rights.
And Yale gave them bragging
rights with all their friends
that we grew up with.
And for me, it was a
ticket out of Michigan
and a ticket to seeing
more of the world,
learning with other people
who are were from Michigan.
And that really appealed to me.
So I thought,
finally, I'll be free.
I can do whatever I want to do
except that my parents said,
well, you've got to do something
that's going to get you a job.
And the thing that's
going to get you a job
is a degree that's going to
lead to either another degree
or business.
So you're either going to
do pre-med or engineering
or pre-law, something like that.
I didn't want to do
any of those things.
But they said, if you want us
to pay for college or at least
part of it, you're going to
have to major in something that
gets you a job.
So my compromise was economics
and political science.
I thought that's
going to set me up
to potentially
apply to law school
because that will lead to
a profession, something
that my parents could say Soojin
is now a lawyer or a doctor
or engineer.
So it was something very clear.
And it was something
that was familiar.
It's something that I
learned about on TV.
Back then, before
there was Google,
back before there was
internet and LinkedIn,
the only way you could know
what career paths were available
were by the people around you--
your parents, their family
and friends, and things
you saw on TV.
So to give you another example,
my husband is a dentist.
And he knew he wanted to be
a dentist from a young age
because he saw the show "Rudolph
the Red-Nosed Reindeer."
how could that have led to
wanting to be a dentist?
There is a character on there.
How many of you
have seen "Rudolph
the Red-Nosed Reindeer?"
OK.
So there are a bunch of elves.
And there's one elf, Hermey, who
says, "I want to be a dentist."
And the head elf says
no, you're a toy maker.
But I'm really interested
in molars and things.
And so when he saw that,
my husband Jim said,
I want to do something that
makes me different, too.
The other thing that
made him realize
he wanted to be a
dentist was, growing up,
he had gone to his
dentist and he was always
singing and whistling.
And this guy was always happy.
And he thought,
when I grow up, I
want a career where
I'm really happy
and fulfilled in my career.
So that's what I want to do.
Even though we ended up in very
different places, what drove us
to our decision was that we
were influenced by the things
that we knew, the people around
us, what we were exposed to.
And back before the internet,
it was really limited.
So most people followed in
the footsteps of their parents
or their parents' friends.
So fast forward to college
and my senior year at Yale.
I had to decide what
am I going to do next.
The obvious thing was
to go to law school.
So to make my parents happy
and be a good Asian kid,
I did apply to law school.
But what I really wanted
to do after taking
a constitutional
law class was work
on policies that would impact
a lot of people for the greater
good.
And I discovered in
the career office
at Yale, public policy school.
And so I sent away for
information for that,
not telling my parents
that I was doing that.
And I got in.
And when it came time
to make a decision,
my parents said, what the heck
is this thing called an MPP?
What are you going to
do when you grow up
after getting that degree?
Does it lead to a job, and
how much will you make?
I was like, I don't know.
I'm just going to take it on
faith that it will work out.
And so it did.
I did get a job.
I became a Presidential
Management Fellow.
And what that program
does is it gives you
leadership training as well
as rotational opportunities
throughout the executive
and legislative branches.
And that's what I did
for a number of years.
And it was great fun to
be in the middle of what
was making news.
It's still making news.
Stuff that happens
in DC makes the news.
It felt exciting.
It felt current.
It felt sexy.
Until I realized, I
am just one little cog
in this big machine that isn't
having an impact on things
that really change the world.
And so I felt pretty
useless, and I thought,
I need to do something else
because my heart isn't really
in it.
It was in it for
the right reasons,
but I wasn't feeling like
I could have that impact.
So the next step
was private sector.
At least there I can feel like
I'm working on something where
I can impact change
pretty quickly, where
I can see the results of
my brain power, my effort,
my working with other people.
So I said, consulting,
that's the thing for me.
It will allow me to
use my brain power.
It will allow me to work
with different people, work
on different projects.
It will be exciting.
It will be sexy.
We're all in search of
sexy to some extent.
So I threw a bunch
of letters out there,
cover letters to all the
top consulting firms.
I got nothing.
I thought, I have a Yale
degree and a Harvard degree.
Surely, that's going
to get me a job.
Guess what?
It doesn't.
It didn't.
Because I didn't know how to
apply for a job like that.
I didn't really
know what it was.
I didn't know how
to talk about what
I would bring to the table.
I didn't know how to talk
about their organizations.
I hadn't done my homework, and
I didn't really know myself.
So I went back to
the drawing board.
The answer is always school.
When you don't know
what to do next,
school is always a good thing.
So I decided to get
my MBA because I still
had it in my mind that I
wanted to do consulting.
I went to the Michigan
Ross School of Business
right here in Ann Arbor and
spent the next two years
doing things that
would set me up
to be able to get
a consulting job.
And I did.
I landed a job at
Deloitte Consulting,
and I did that for
about five years.
And it gave me some of the
things that I was looking for,
which was using my brain
power to make change
in an organization
that I could see.
But after a number of years
of doing that, again, I
felt my heart saying,
I need something more.
So I had to think about, what is
that more that I'm looking for?
And that more was
personal meaning,
where I'm having an
impact on something that
makes somebody else's life
better, where it's getting
someone more opportunities.
That's about all I knew about
what I wanted to do next.
And so I had to
really think about,
what are the jobs out there that
can give me that, where I can
use my skills and get the
feeling that I want in my gut,
in my soul about having impact?
So I just started talking
to a lot of people, people
who do different things
in their careers,
and learning what do they
do, what is it all about.
And as it turns out,
one of my conversations
was with the woman
who had recruited
me to come work at Deloitte.
She was a manager at the time.
And as soon as I took the offer,
she said, guess what, Soojin?
I'm leaving.
I'm so glad you signed.
You made me look good, but I'm
going to go do something else.
I was like, what the heck?
I joined because I
wanted to work with you.
As it turned out, she went to
go see the admissions director
at the Ross School of Business.
And over the next five years
that I worked at Deloitte,
I kept in touch with her.
And having those
conversations with her
helped lead me to my current job
at the Ross School of Business.
We talked about,
what do I like doing?
What is it about
some of the roles
that I've had that really
excited me, brought me joy,
made me feel like I was
having the kind of impact
that I wanted?
And it was a number of things.
One was, in my free time,
I am an alumni interviewer
for Yale undergrad.
And one of the things
I love about that
is understanding people--
what motivates them,
their dreams, and is there
a good fit between what they
want to do, what they've done,
and what that school can offer.
So that was one thing.
Another thing I realized
was, at Deloitte, I really
enjoyed recruiting
new MBAs because it
was an avenue to opportunities.
It was promoting an organization
that I really loved.
And then, I also liked
using my analytical skills
in consulting,
figuring out how do
I make something work better,
how do I get more of something,
how do I make it as good
a process and experience
for people who engage
with my organization--
whether it's Deloitte
or Yale or Michigan.
How do I make those
things happen?
And so when I described
these things to her,
it became obvious to her and to
me that recruiting at Michigan
might be a good fit.
And opportunity happened
to present itself.
She had an open slot there.
That's how I got
here 13 years ago,
and I haven't looked back
because the things that
keep me here are some
of the same things I
was looking for in a job--
feeling like I have an impact
on people's lives and that help
them have better opportunities
in their own lives,
getting to use my
analytical skills--
the things that I learned
in the MBA program--
and working in an
organization that I feel
is mission driven and
helps other people
and is doing really
exciting things.
It's sexy to work on
leadership and innovation
and entrepreneurship
and all those things,
and I'm surrounded
by faculty, students,
and alumni who do that.
And so when people
ask me, what's next?
I say, why should there be a
what's next if I'm learning
and I'm growing and
I love what I do.
Because ultimately, isn't
that what we're looking for?
At least one of
those three things.
But if you have all
three of those things,
you kind of have that trifecta.
So as I think about
advice to people
who are early in
their career, how
can you find the thing that
will make your heart sing,
I have a few things.
One is to research and explore.
Really, talk to a lot of people.
Every person that
you meet is going
to be able to teach
you something.
I met Devan maybe seven, eight
years ago not professionally
but through an alumni event.
DAVANG SHAH: We were
planting flowers.
SOOJIN KWON: We planted
flowers together.
He and his wife in
downtown Ann Arbor,
we were all doing
volunteer work that day.
And we happened to
develop a relationship
that, over the last seven years,
I've watched him have two kids.
He's seen my kids grow up.
I'm here now largely
because of him.
And meeting Angel-- are
you still in here, Angel?
I met her at Devan's house,
and we had a great conversation
about some of the things that
she did in undergrad that I
was really inspired about--
her initiative and her drive
for creating a TED Talk
series at her institution.
I was really excited to
hear things that people do,
and it makes me want to know
them and know other people.
The other thing,
second thing, is
to reflect on what's
important to you
and where you are in your life.
What's right for you
really depends on where
you are in your stage of life.
Who's in your life?
Who do you need to take care of?
Do you have a significant other?
Do you have children?
Do you have parents who
need to be taken care of?
Or can you, right now,
focus on yourself?
That should influence the
choices that you make.
And the other thing is, what
do you need to do in your life
right now?
Do you have a lot of
other obligations?
Do you have personal goals
that you want to fit in?
Or, can you really
focus on career?
Those things can
help you figure out
what is the next career for me.
Because, at different
times in your life,
those things are
going to change.
And the last thing I
would encourage you to do
is to stop and reflect.
Reflect on, what have I
done so far in my life?
What have I learned?
With the people
that I've talked to,
what seems really interesting?
How did they get there?
What can I learn from them
or about how to get there?
And if you don't
do this already,
I would encourage you
to keep a journal.
And I know it can be hard.
I find it hard myself.
But keep a journal of the things
that you learn about yourself,
of the things that
were hard, how
you've tackled some of
those problems, things
you want to change about how you
might approach something, goals
that you have, but taking
quiet time to sit down
and reflect about those things.
That can help you also narrow
down what it is you want to do.
You guys are really lucky that
you work in a great place,
that you live in a time when
you can find out information
about anything about anyone
anywhere in the world,
and you can connect with them.
You are only a few
degrees of separation
away from someone
who may want to meet.
In some ways, that
might be harder
because that makes
it seem overwhelming,
all those opportunities
that you could have.
But if you do those three
things that I suggested--
research and talk to
people, think about
where you are in
your life right now,
and sitting down and reflecting
on what's important to you,
what you've done, and
who you want to be--
that can help narrow
your focus a bit.
One of the most exciting things
about meeting new people for me
is thinking about new ways of
doing things and new things
to do.
And some people may
call that networking.
I really call it
getting to know people.
It's a really valuable skill.
And I have to put in a plug,
of course, for getting an MBA.
[LAUGHTER]
And here's why.
Because I will contend that,
more than any other degree,
that's going to open up a
broader range of opportunities.
It can be opportunities
financially,
opportunities industry
function-wise, opportunities
to meet different people.
If you are a dentist or
a doctor or an attorney,
your career is that.
It will be almost invariably
that for the rest of your life.
But when you get
an MBA, there's so
many things you can
do that may or may not
be related to business.
What it teaches you are
ways to think about things,
problem solve, and to
work with other people.
And that's what we're going
to have to do in any field.
And so I contend that an MBA
is the most valuable degree,
the most flexible degree
you can have out there.
And if you're going to do one,
you should get it at Michigan.
I'll stop there and
turn it over to Devan.
DAVANG SHAH: Well,
first of all, thank you.
It's incredibly insightful
to hear about your journey,
more insightful to hear about
how you've made decisions
at every stage in your life.
I'll start with a
handful of questions.
And as I'm asking
questions, I'll
ask all the folks in
the room to also start
thinking about questions
or jotting them down.
But let's start, one of the
things that really struck
me is how you made decisions
at every stage in your life
based on a little bit of
something that felt uneasy,
something in your
gut, something that
meant that you needed to
think about this itch that
was kind of happening and
a change that you needed.
So I'd love for you to
talk about how you thought
about those decisions
and then, ultimately,
any sort of guidance.
A lot of the folks in
this room are either
in their first job or their
second job out of school
and will soon be coming to
those points of inflection,
so any guidance you can
provide there would be useful.
SOOJIN KWON: OK.
So there were many
things that made
making these decisions
challenging for me
along the way.
Part of it is my own
culture and heritage--
being Asian, obviously--
wanting to please my parents
and make them proud.
That is something that, even
now as I'm approaching 50,
it looms really large in my
head the decisions that I make.
And so what I
wanted to do wasn't
always what they
wanted me to do,
and reconciling that
was really hard.
The other was reconciling
kind of my background
and what I want to do.
Is this the career
path of someone
who went to Yale and Harvard?
To be an admissions director?
Who grows up wanting to do that?
Getting an MBA and then being an
admissions director eventually?
Who grows up wanting to do that?
So it felt like a very
nontraditional, unconventional
decision to make.
And I'll be honest, I
have a lot of pride.
Like, I want people to say,
wow, she's done something
really great with her life.
She is accomplishing a lot.
And given the path
that I was on,
it wasn't always clear
to me that the choice
that I've made in this
role was an obvious one.
It takes a lot of courage
to say, but you know what?
I love this.
I'm learning.
I'm contributing.
I'm making an impact.
I can make change.
And I'm meeting
really great people.
It took a lot of courage for
me to say those things outweigh
all the other image-related
things that I was so mired in.
And probably at a
younger age, it's
harder to do that because you
feel like there are things
that you need to
do, maybe things
that you need to prove either to
your family or to your friends
or to yourself.
But at the end of the day,
what I've come to conclude--
and I can because I'm
further in my career now--
is, unless it's really
making you thrive,
unless you feel like my heart
is singing this, I'm learning,
I'm growing, I'm doing
things that matter to me,
then you're just
spinning wheels.
Then it's just a job.
And nobody wants
to have just a job.
You want to have something
that makes you get up and say,
I can't wait to do this again.
I love the people
I work with I love
the things that I get to do I
can't wait to do more of this.
And when you stop doing
that, when you stop learning,
when you stop
growing, and when you
stop being able to feel
like you're contributing,
that's the time to rethink
what's the next thing.
DAVANG SHAH: Thanks, Soojin.
One more question
along the same lines.
As the folks in this
room are thinking
about their next steps, I think
often in the conversations
I've had and I've heard
happening there's this almost
conflict of, do I pursue
something I'm really passionate
about versus going to get an MBA
and what role they both play.
How would you guide
the folks in this room
to think about that conflict?
SOOJIN KWON: I guess it comes
down to a timing thing, right.
If they think an MBA
is in your future,
when is the right time to do it?
There really isn't a wrong
time because now there
are so many different
times in your career
that you can get it.
The standard path is
with a full-time MBA,
coming out of undergrad,
working for a number of years,
and then going back to get
your MBA before you're 30.
There are also
programs like at Ross
where you can do it part time
while you're working full time.
And then there are programs like
at Ross where you can get it
when you've been working
for 10 or more years
as an executive MBA.
And it's at a different
level that you'll get it.
So there's never a wrong time.
If you have a great professional
opportunity, don't give it up.
If you feel like you're
continuing to do something
where you're learning
and you're growing,
and if you took
yourself off that path
to go get an MBA at that
point, then wait a year.
But if you feel like there
are skills that I can gain now
that only the MBA could provide
and my current job can't, that
might be the right
time to get it as well.
DAVANG SHAH: Thanks.
It's a good transition to
thinking about MBAs in general.
How would you
describe Ross and what
you think makes Ross unique?
SOOJIN KWON: One
of the things that
attracted me to Ross
almost 20 years ago
and still holds true today
is that it's really focused
on allowing you to
do things hands-on.
Not just sitting in class
and learning about theories
and applying frameworks
to simulations,
but really getting
out and doing things
that you might want
to do, whether it's
consulting or managing a fund
or starting up a business.
All of those things
you can do at Ross
while you're a student with
faculty and alumni advisors,
with resources
that are not yours
that you're putting at risk,
with the help of classmates
who have done some of the
things that you may want to do.
And so it's an
incredible place where,
if you want to actually
do things and not
just learn the theory behind
it, you'll get that, too.
There's no better place to
do that than it at Ross.
DAVANG SHAH: Thanks.
And when you think about the
role of an MBA in context
of a person's career
path, their life path,
how has that changed over
the last 10 or 20 years?
SOOJIN KWON: I'd say
it's changed quite a bit.
If you look at the industries
that students go into,
the recruiters that come
to campus, the choices
that students make about
their careers post-MBA,
it's just exploded.
25 years ago, people used to
take pretty standard paths--
banking, marketing, consulting.
Those were really the three
buckets that people went into.
Now, people are doing
all kinds of things.
They are starting up
their own businesses.
There are so many different
kinds of tech jobs,
as you guys know.
There are still students who
go into consulting and finance
and marketing, but those are
not as big as they used to be.
And it's no longer a career
for life as so many people
who got MBAs back in
the day used to be.
It's you do one thing
for a few years,
and then you may pivot your
career in any number of ways.
And the beauty of the MBA
now is it's giving you
the skills and the
access to pivot
your career multiple
times, which students now
are going to be doing much
more than even students
from my generation.
DAVANG SHAH: So I think
that's one observation I have.
I've been in the
workforce for 20 years.
And when I started,
candidly, I would
think getting a job
meant a job for life.
And now, people are
changing careers
quite frequently,
probably five to 10 times
over the course of
their entire careers.
What advice do you have
in context of careers
and when people are thinking
about making those switches?
SOOJIN KWON: The advice I'd
give is to learn from every role
that you have.
Learn not just the skills that
are required for the position
that you're in, but also
learn about yourself.
What motivates you?
What about that particular
role at that time
really interested
you so that you
can get closer to what
it is that's going
to be your nirvana.
And it may change
over time, too.
I never knew that I would
love speaking as much as I do,
frankly.
It used to scare
the heck out of me,
and you could never
get me to be the person
to stand in front of a
class or a large group
to volunteer to speak.
And now, through
this role, because I
had to, because I've
done it quite a bit,
and because I enjoy
sharing what I know,
I've learned that I love
something that I never would
have imagined that I love.
So it's exposing yourself
to different things
and getting good at everything,
even if you don't love it,
because you may find
eventually you do love it
and that's the thing that
makes you say, this is so fun.
I can't wait to do it again.
DAVANG SHAH: So in your
role, you obviously
shape both the admissions
and what the class looks
like, and you also shape
what the program looks like.
I'd love to hear from
your perspective, what
are some of the biggest
mistakes applicants make?
And then also, in context
of students who are actually
pursuing and already
in the program,
what are those mistakes?
What are the things people
should be looking out for?
SOOJIN KWON: I think the biggest
mistakes both as an applicant
and as a student
are quite the same.
It's inauthenticity.
It's trying to be
someone that you're not,
trying to make yourself
at the applicant stage
look like the
quintessential MBA applicant
rather than really just talking
about yourself as you are
and what you want to do.
These days, unlike
20 or more years ago,
there is no cookie cutter.
There is no traditional
MBA candidate.
They are so different.
We have people coming
from the Peace Corps
and from Teach for America
and from the military,
from nonprofits, from medicine.
This wasn't standard when 20,
30 years ago my classmates
and before me we're
going to school.
I was a nontraditional student
going to business school
at that time.
Most of my classmates
had come from some kind
of business role.
I came from Capitol Hill.
I felt like a fish out of water.
But that's not uncommon anymore.
Students are coming with
really different backgrounds.
Yet, a lot of
applicants think they
have to look like the perfect
business school applicant.
Same thing for when
students are in the program.
They get sucked into the,
oh, I should do consulting
because everybody else
is doing consulting,
or I should do finance
because everybody else is
doing finance.
Business school
is an opportunity
to learn what's out there and to
learn what really motivates you
and then really jumping
into learning those things.
So you shouldn't
have to feel that you
need to be this quintessential
MBA student either.
Or, post-MBA, you
don't need to do
the career paths at all of
your classmates are doing.
The beauty of the degree
is it's giving you
options to do different things.
And so I would encourage
you guys to have the courage
to do really different things.
DAVANG SHAH: Thank you.
One more question about
the program and the class.
How are you thinking about
creating a diverse environment
both from a perspective
of the content
but also the program
makeup in the students
and creating an environment
that's inclusive?
SOOJIN KWON: I can't tell
you how important diversity
is to us, to me personally.
This year, I'm really proud
that our women numbers
are at a record high,
at 43% in the MBA class.
I would love that to be
50-50, more in line with what
you see at the undergrad level.
We truly believe that,
without a diverse class,
you're not going
to learn as much.
Without people from
different backgrounds
with different
experiences who are
going to make you think about
things in a different way,
you're just going to be
thinking the same way
that you were before.
And the whole point of school
is to learn different ways
of thinking about things.
It's about how your mind works
and how you approach situations
and problems.
And if everyone comes from the
same industry or the same life
circumstances, you're
not going to grow.
Our job is to give you
an environment where
you are going to grow the
most, and that is in large part
through the classmates
that you have.
So we are so focused
on making sure
that the student body looks
very diverse not just in terms
of gender, but color,
nationality, backgrounds,
geographies, career goals.
All those things
matter because we
want you to learn from people
who are different from you.
DAVANG SHAH: That's great.
Last question.
This is one to be a little
more playful and fun.
You're applying
for an MBA program.
Yes, I told you and
I'm holding to it.
You're applying
to an MBA program.
You can't apply to Ross.
What other program
do you apply to?
SOOJIN KWON: OK.
I will give a nod to you just
because he's the co-host here.
Devan went to Yale
School of Management.
And that's my undergrad,
so it does have
a special place in my heart.
And that's how I
got to meet him.
But I'm not endorsing it.
[LAUGHTER]
I'll tell you where we have the
most overlaps in applications
because we have visibility into
that from GMAT test takers.
And that is we overlap largely
with Kellogg, with Duke,
with Wharton,
Berkeley, Yale, Tuck.
All of those are great schools.
The thing is, any of those
schools are going to be great.
It's about you making the
most of the opportunities
that you have wherever you are.
But of course, I'm pretty
partial to Michigan.
The student body
and the opportunity
do action-based
learning, it's really
different from all the
other schools in my opinion.
But I encourage you to
check it out yourself.
If you're thinking
about business school,
talk to students.
Talk to alums in every school
that you're considering.
Go visit because you're going
to get a feel for the school
and for the vibe
there because that's
going to make the difference
between whether you get an MBA
or you have this
great springboard
for ideas and opportunities.
So it's about finding
the right place for you,
and you'll hear every
admissions director say that.
DAVANG SHAH: Thank you
for the authentic answer.
And it is very true.
I think your
perspective, when you
make that decision to
go pursue a degree,
it's not just about the MBA.
It's about changing
the way you think,
and it can have a
profound impact.
So thank you.